hello everybody my name is Jacob Collier
and I'm a musician I've been challenged
today to explain one simple concept in
five levels of increasing complexity my
topic harmony I'm positive that
everybody can leave this video with some
understanding at some level od how's it
going good
cool so do you know what harmony is it's
when people sing together and it sounds
nice yeah
that's 100% correct have you ever heard
a song called amazing grace yeah here's
a good one the melody on its own just
goes that melody on its own is kind of
lonely right and no one really knows how
it feels
so which one did you prefer second one
awesome and why did you prefer that one
because it sounds better yeah oh that's
great I can decide how I want this
ability to feel and the more notes there
are the more exciting it is that's what
musical harmony is does that make sense
thank you have you ever heard of harmony
yes okay so what do you think harmony is
I think basically it's like one person
has the lower voice and like a girl
usually has the higher voice yeah and
then they blend it together I like it
that's absolutely correct harmony is
about injecting melody with emotion or
so that ultimately you leave home and
you return home and you've learned
something along the way yeah so a nice
place to start is with the idea of a
triad I've tried is a three-part
harmonic basically so that's a trap you
know so this try it's called C major
alright so have you ever heard this idea
of like major chords and minor chords
yeah so this is C major yeah and then
this is C C minor so the feelings are
different right yeah I feels like
darkness yeah how does this will make
you feel them right yeah like yeah so in
Amazing Grace you start with F you know
if I go
and my job is to get back home but to
make it to make this cord make sense
yeah so I'm like
my job as a harmonizer is to find that
narrative and make it make sense that
was interesting because I didn't think
that that would work together right
because there are two completely
different sounds but then like it just
made it happen this is like essentially
what harmony is is like a language right
and so as with any language the more
words you're capable of speaking in a
language the more you can say all right
so in harmony this might be how many
notes you can think to add to a chord to
make it feel a different way have you
ever heard of the circle of fifths mmm
okay that's great on one side we have a
lot of the notes which make us feel
brighter you know like these kinds of
these rewrite sounds and the other side
is a lot more to do with the darkness of
a key Center so we're having F but
imagine we're taking a quick visit to B
flat but then the Sun comes out oh yeah
yeah what notes would you suggest I add
F F is a great one yeah and if we keep
going in that direction yeah I see yeah
and then G yeah yeah so this is really
this is like a gleaming blade or
something you know let's play this tune
amazing grace let's play it in its
simplest form yeah all right so we're
gonna sign F right yes
yeah nice okay cool let's try one more
version will we ask some colors all
right so let's visit the B flat with a
bit more imagination this is how things
feel yeah all right listen let's do it
so it's fmaj7 but it's over a just f7
over a b flat major seven with an a
energy in it F major seven with an E and
a DRG D minor 7 with the g-unit cease us
for minor nice b flat major
g7 that felt major 7 like that
so what harmony does is just gives us
even more tools to tell those stories
yeah an awesome one nice emotional
device when it comes to harmony is just
think about how to arrive somewhere you
know it can be so sparse it can be so
rich and it can be really emotional so
this idea of the overtone are understood
in the harmonic series how much do you
know about this only until I started
listening to singing like barbershop
quartet and and as I was a violinist as
well then I finally understood that day
where the overtone series came from that
if a bunch of singers were to a nail a
chord or have it perfectly tuned the
overtones you would hear a tone that
necessarily wasn't being produced by one
of the chairs the amazing about harmony
is that it exists in nature
so take that morning series of the note
F for example K you have the option in
the 5th and the 4th and then that's a
little bit sharper that's both and then
the intervals get increasingly small
beneath that note you have the under
tone series which essentially is like a
reflection or something in the same way
that when a tree grows in nature you
have the branches which go upwards in
the roots which go downwards so it's
quite a nice thing to think about this
being the key Center that the floor the
ground and then these two different
directions of ways in which it can
express itself and the difference is in
the sensations with that lots of the
time I think when it comes to
reharmonization or harmonization people
think that the solution to the problems
come when we add more notes mm-hmm yeah
I think that people forget that you can
work with the notes already have by just
rearranging them just the simple idea of
inversion you know in version of the
simple triad of F major so
Oh
see know how home do I want to go here
you know
is there another verse to come right
because I can do I can delay the
gratification of going home first of all
just by using inversions even before we
add notes to the chord one thing that I
was very joyful to discover is that
every single melody note works with
every single bass note hmm so you
demonstrate that yeah so this is the
note there yeah F major F minor G flat
major seven G flat diminished G flat
minor major seven G minor seven cheese
sauce g7 g7 sharp eleven and then g7
with a flat 13 but a flat sauce flat
major seven a flat major seven sharp
five with a sharp 11 essentially what
that demonstrates is that every note and
every bass note are compatible so once
we realize this it's like that's great
now what should we do what should we
watch what would what am I supposed to
do right and sometimes the power lies
anything when it comes to arranging
there are too many options too many
things are possible so that's when it
becomes super super important to be
aware of what you want to try and say
emotionally you know what about negative
harmony the dark side so essentially the
way I'd apply negative harmony would be
this idea of polarity you know between
the undertones there is new overtone
series or you know the one side the
other side the perfect in the play go
the feeling of a minor playful cadence
resolving is so moving you know and it's
just it's a good alternative to
something like 22 you know what you
doing that makes something in a major
key sound the kind of a wistful sad song
right you know I'll change the feeling
of that what otherwise would you know if
you would tell the kid that this is a
major song should be happy
exactly yeah no for sure an inner F
major can be something you arrive in
from if you arrive in F major from D
flat yeah that is like the sun's come
out right but if you arrive an F major
from a major
and it's like the sun's going in there's
a lot about context I think once you
have a language it's about using it and
applying it and there's emotional ways I
think that's what makes the difference
all right a lot of people will see you
as somebody who's drank in harmony their
whole life they've seen so much harmony
heard so much harmony how do you make
the choices there's so much that's
possible when you know stuff how do you
how do you have the courage to make a
choice it comes from just your life
experience mm-hmm and and that moves you
in a certain direction how it gets
expressed many times it's a complete
surprise I find it fascinating in music
to think about you know say I arrive in
a place if I'm going I'm going to D flat
major and there was something you once
taught me you taught me this song called
don't follow the crowd oh yeah and
there's that chord it's not a dominant
chord but it functions as a dominant
chord and it doesn't matter because
you're still going to the place you're
going to right right right it's
something like
right right so this called being like a
major 7 with a Saab 5 and a natural like
there's no dominant there but at that
moment I'm coming from here and I want
to afford some some solution I get
myself in a situation that haunted me
for days you know I just wouldn't think
to use that cord in that situation yeah
and there it was and yeah you know if
you read the rulebook it's that's not in
it yeah and it this is what I learned
from the great person Sanderson yeah
yeah yeah the idea of going to D flat
chord normally there's a dominant black
day flat 7 we're back in the twenties
they also you used to do things like
yeah
so it's come
coming from just just below the keep you
from c-27
and we don't normally say a c7 and and a
flat seven all right I related yeah you
know because some of that so many of the
notes are different it's not even but if
you've always that correctly oh yeah
then you're safe you can get all you can
get away with it yeah
the other thing that I like that
we both do on occasion is to be on the
court we want to arrive at with the
bottom part of our structure and accord
before the arrival court to have that on
top yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
and that's not because like emotionally
it's almost like I'm here I'm arriving
here but if the base new is the same
it's like this inevitability about it
makes a pool yeah yeah it's like one
thing is moving in one direction one
thing has arrived so it's this tension
and it's right glorious I love thinking
like these things emotionally just
because that's a feeling you I know that
feeling in my life music isn't that
different from life no you know and I
think that's probably the greatest
attraction to those of us who play music
yeah
was there ever a point in your life when
you were younger where you felt like you
had consistently fell back into the same
habits you'd finally I'm not gonna play
the same thing again I had a really
great experience when I was working with
Miles Davis I felt like I was in a rut
playing the same stuff and I was getting
depressed because of it and Miles said
something to me I thought he said don't
play the butter notes right and so I
thought what do you mean by that
so you thought it said butter butter no
he said bottom but you thought he said
butter yeah Wow inside sad thing oh quit
what quit butter be what is better then
I said thing what are the obvious notes
that for example in a chord the obvious
notes are the third in the seventh hmm
so I said oh maybe if I leave those out
it changed everything for me from that
moment on I got more applause than for
that song than I did the whole week
well I wouldn't played the voicings I
play today if that had not happened
that's amazing you know I've been using
this tune amazing grace oh and so we
could play a bit of that if you want to
okay we could talk about some stuff I'll
be doing an F
thank you